and speaking of big decisions the final
four will face off Sunday on Dancing
with the Stars jr. so here's the
question are these little tiny dancers
feeling the pressure what we've had
their mentors find out how does it feel
to make the semi-finals of the
first-ever Dancing with the Stars junior
competition joining eleven-year-old
Avenger star ariana Greenblatt is
ten-year-old Skye Brown the world's
youngest pro skateboarder I would have
made a fun I wouldn't have made it this
far without you
rounding out the Final Four
thirteen-year-old blackish star miles
Brown I've been filming blackish almost
all season and they know we've had it
like FaceTime that's how they would
teach me most of their dances that's
pretty crazy and singer and YouTube star
fourteen-year-old Mackenzie Ziegler
everyone is like very cute and I feel
like we're like the Oh your tags on the
show you kind of have to like work for
it so how do these juniors plan on
making it to the finals well it'll work
as hard as we can we gotta lock in focus
in we gotta just perform our buoys off I
think we're just gonna dance like
nobody's watching I couldn't really
focus these these weeks because I've
been thinking about like the end too
much and what exactly about that have
you been thinking about
[Music]
okay kids tell the truth
I really do by the way all 12 kid
couples will be back a week from Sunday
for a holiday theme the season for now
[Music]